willkommen bei philo cast einer neuen
folge diesmal mit professor harald lesch
hallo hallo
sie sind ja nicht nur physiker sondern
auch philosophisch in der lehre tätig
und vielleicht auch in der forschung ja
also wir arbeiten an selbstorganisation
komplexen system also philosophie von
der frage wie entsteht etwas neues zu
komplexen system gibt es ja das große
thema des klimas was ja auch ein
komplexes system
jaja das klima das klima ist momentan
nicht so gut was das klima betrifft also
was soll ich sagen
aktuell ist es halt so dass alle zeichen
darauf stehen dass die situation dass
der erde sich sehr schnell verändert
schneller als wir jemals gedacht haben
wir haben anzeichen auf der ganzen welt
wirklich vom nordpol bis zum südpol dass
es überall wärmer wird und zwar deutlich
wärmer und selbst hier in deutschland
hat man inzwischen schon wahrgenommen
dass noch so ein paar warme sommer
unseren wald umbringen wird die flüsse
austrocknen wird also allmählich kommt
uns der klimawandel eben immer näher und
naja gibt es neben diesen politisch
wirtschaftlichen diskussionen die mir
jetzt persönlich in den medien auffallen
die sind sehr politisch geprägt gibt es
auch hier an sich nach philosophische
aufgaben oder moralische ableitungen die
wir für uns dafür nehmen können na ja
natürlich also es gibt von hans jonas ja
das klassische werk prinzip
verantwortung wird darauf hingewiesen
wird dass eben wir heutzutage damals
schon 40 jahre alt tatsächlich in der
lage sind über unseren lebensraum und
über unsere lebenszeit hinaus wirkungen
zu vollziehen weil wir so potent die
menschheit ist mit ihren technischen
möglichkeiten so potent geworden dass
sie bleiben manipulation an der natur
herstellen kann
wo die generation die es ausführt gar
nicht dass mehr mit kriegen wird sondern
erst generationen später wird man merken
was da los ist
insofern sind die wirkungen mit denen
wir momentan zu tun haben schon
auswirkungen der
der 80 jahre der 70er und 80er jahre wo
wir eben schon angefangen haben jede
menge kohlendioxid in die luft zu jagen
aber dann so richtig losgegangen ist es
eben erst in den 90er jahren seitdem
haben wir die effekte der treibhausgase
in der atmosphäre verdoppelt also das
heißt wir haben richtig viel rein gejagt
und das obwohl der treibhauseffekt also
der effekt dass es eben moleküle in der
atmosphäre gibt die die wärmestrahlung
der erde absorbieren
bereits seit 1824 bekannt ist damals hat
ein franzose jean baptist foyer zum
ersten mal darüber gesprochen und zwar
aus einer ganz anderen situation aus hat
er mich gefragt es gab offenbar
eiszeiten es war die zeit wo man zum
ersten mal festgestellt hat es gab
eiszeiten und wollte man wissen wie ist
denn die erde wieder warm geworden
also wenn die erde mal so kalt war sie
hat die überhaupt bitte also genau das
umgekehrte das ist das irre
und dann sagt schrieb vorleben naja die
sichtbare sichtbare licht der sonne
kommt rein und dann wird die erde
erwärmt und offenbar wird die strahlung
die die erde dann abgibt von der
atmosphäre in teilen geben lauf genommen
und dann wieder zurückgestellt anders
könne man sich das nicht erklären
856 man muss sich das mal überlegen hat
zum ersten mal eine frau evelyn futti
hat zum ersten mal verschiedene zylinder
voll unterschiedlichem atmosphärischen
zusammensetzungen genommen hat sie
bestrahlt und hat festgestellt am
wärmsten wird der zylinder mit
kohlendioxid drin
das heißt wir wissen dass alles schon
sehr lange und es ist natürlich ganz
besonders schlimm in diesem in diesem
sinne wenn man wenn man mal die
zeitskala betrachtet wie lange wir schon
ahnen können zumindestens im
spezialisten gruppen schon sehr sehr
lange und inzwischen in der
öffentlichkeit seit 50 jahren was wir
hätten tun müssen und dann sieht man das
natürlich eine moralische debatte eine
debatte über unsere ethischen
perspektiven wären dringend angesagt und
wir leben offenbar in dem widerspruch
der ökonomischen zwanghaftigkeit dass
wir haben aus den aus dem wachstums
imperativen nicht rauskommen einerseits
und auf der anderen seite sehen wir
natürlich wir müssten also auf die frage
was sollen wir denn tun haben wir
endlich eine klare antworten ganz
deutlich aber wir können es nicht weil
es eben andere andere interessen gibt
die es die das verhindern also das
problem an dass ich stoße und vielleicht
auch viele unserer zuschauer
die sind zu sagen die meisten denke ich
sind studierende hier und sind sich das
bewusst dass der klimawandel existiert
sogar der menschen gemacht der jetzt
habe ich aber auch oft die situation
erlebt das ist ein leute gibt die wir
reden darüber
der fall stellt sich aus die diese
bezweifeln dass sie komplett und da wär
halt meine frage was hätten sie dafür
ein schlag
das könnte ich da sagen na ja also das
ist natürlich ganz ganz schwierig erst
mal ist es so dass eine inhaltliche
debatte über jemand der das total
anzweifelt damit werden ja
wissenschaftliche methoden angezweifelt
und zwar sowohl die methodik der
empirischen wissenschaft wo ja eine
theorie immer an der erfahrung scheitern
können muss das ist die philosophische
forderungs keine forderung die aus den
naturwissenschaften selber kommt sondern
dass es kritische rationalismus porsche
forderung eine empirische prothese muss
an der erfahrung scheitern können man
muss experimente machen können
beobachtungen die diese these bestätigen
und das ist eben tatsächlich ja also bei
dem klimawandel wissen wir genau diese
anthropogen ist und zwar kann ich das
mal kurz erklären weil das ist ein es
ist so es gibt einen kohlenstoff isotope
isotop von einem chemischen element ist
eines mit der gleichen anzahl von
protonen aber unterschiedlich vielen
elektrischen neutralen neutronen das
sind also atomkern ist ein bisschen
schwerer oder ein bisschen leichter als
der normale kern von einem element
kohlenstoff zum beispiel hat
normalerweise sechs protonen und 693 und
deswegen sagt man c 12 das ist stabil
der nächste mit einem neutron mehr c13
ist auch stabil und der nächste c14 mit
zwei neutronen mehr der ist instabil und
der zerfällt nach 5760 jahren und aller
dinge überhaupt schonmal jemals was von
altersbestimmung gehört haben die kennen
die c14 methode
das ist ein ganz wichtiges isotop um zb
das alter von mumien und so weiter zu
bestimmen und das zerfällt nach 5760
jahren also nach ungefähr zehn
halbwertszeiten also sagen wir nach
60.000 jahren ist da kein c 14 wenn wir
hier zu kohle und öl aus dem boden holen
bisher uhr altes zeugs millionen jahre
80 millionen jahre und verbrennen das
dann pumpen wir also die atmosphäre voll
mit kohlenstoff vogue 114 mehr drin ist
denn es gibt eine natürliche verteilung
von kohlenstoff wird sein und da unten
kommt aber jetzt nur noch kohlenstoff
nach und der besteht aus material das
ursprünglich zu seiner zeit aus
photosynthetischen prozessen abgelehnt
die photosynthese bevorzugt nun wieder
10 12 statt sie 13
das heißt wir erhöhen den c12 anteil
wieso das heißt man kann an der
kohlenstoff isotope zusammensetzung der
atmosphäre genau sehen wir sind es nur
wir sonst niemand weil der normale
kohlenstoffkreislauf wo zum beispiel
durch vulkane oder sowas kohlenstoff aus
dem boden kommt da sind alle alle
isotope drinnen ja das heißt wir können
wir können direkt nachweisen dass wir
sind und wenn dann alles auch nur glaube
ich nicht dass mir alles nicht kennen
keine isotope und auch sonst
da ist das ein angriff auf eigentlich
eine pokales unternehmen das wir
wissenschaft nennen ja und dann sieht
man natürlich daran dass wir in der art
und weise wie wir diese
wissenschaftlichen inhalt präsentiert
haben und sie der öffentlichkeit nach
gebracht haben offenbar ein riesenfehler
gemacht haben weil wir geglaubt haben
alleine der inhalt würde überzeugt das
gelingt offenbar nicht nur nicht mehr
sondern wir müssen ganz anders vorgehen
und können zum beispiel vielleicht über
eine ethische dimension menschen dazu
bringen das richtige zu tun weil wir
weil man ihnen sagen kann mensch denkt
doch mal an deine kinder ja so und da
wäre halt auch der punkt so zu sagen wo
ich denke wir haben wie sie gesagt haben
konkrete methoden die wir was verändern
können es gibt tausende von tipps und
und wir kennen wir kennen das schon hier
und dann halt die frage was sie davon
halten wenn man vielleicht einfach so
ein schritt zu den skeptikern geht und
sagt selbst wenn der klimawandel nicht
existiert nun die möglichkeit dass er
existiert sollte uns zu ethischen
verantwortung bringen die möglichkeit
für den klimawandel kann man ja also die
kann man nur schwer an zweifeln
sie sagen in anlehnung an diesen
passagen gottesbeweis wenn sie den haben
wo man sagt sein wenn dort nicht
existiert ist egal was ich im leben
mache aber die möglichkeit das existiert
bringt mir halt das ding das ich
irgendwie genau das wäre natürlich eine
art und weise sich von von ed einer
anderen perspektive mit dem thema
auseinanderzusetzen nur lassen sie
lassen die leute sich darauf ein wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass sozusagen
hinter all diesen wissenschaftlichen
erklärungen steckt die psychologie der
beteiligten das heißt ihre geschichte
ihre ihre
sozialisierung und so weiter und dann
merkt man ganz deutlich dass sehr viele
klima skeptiker sind ältere männer und
das bedeutet mit dem stichwort
klimawandel und energiewende wird ihre
lebensleistung angezweifelt dass nämlich
das wirtschaftswunderland deutschland
dass der name zweiten weltkrieg mit
rauchenden schornsteinen usw
weltberühmt geworden ist das offenbar
diese art und weise der lebensführung
natur zerstören das und dass ihnen das
heute vorgeworfen hat ich finde es
interessant dass bei frau des vaters
sind junge frauen auf der straße und bei
den klimaskeptikern älter alte männer
das ist eine frage die wahrscheinlich
nichts mit philosophie zu tun hat aber
ich finde es als phänomen
hochinteressant vielen dank
und bis zu einer nächsten folge danke
fürs vorbeischauen